[Musique]
notre maison brûle toujours qui
endouterait désormais et pourtant toute
décision face à cette urgence absolue et
souvent ressenti comme une contribution
quasi sacrificielle requise des
générations présentes finançant des
mesures à destination des générations
futures la contrainte écologique se
double d'une contrainte économique et
rien n'est négociable s'ajoute la
contrainte de la gouvernance de bien
public mondiaux mais si le ciel est à
tout le monde ce qui est à tout le monde
est à personne dès lors qu'il ne s'agit
plus de profiter mais de financer
l'humanité partage la propriété commune
d'une planète en souffrance que certains
acceptent d'entretenir aux bénéfices du
plus grand nombre mais nul marcher pour
exclure ses opportunistes freeriders
une fiscalité punitive ou encore un
marché des droits à polluer mais vouloir
freiner l'anthropocène en tentant de
généraliser économie circulaire report
modal ou sobriété énergétique ou
numérique c'est risqué de réduire les
acquis de l'innovation quand on
conférence internationale elle peine à
convaincre les pays au-delà de
l'engagement de passer à l'action les
réticences justifiées par des
contraintes de financement à l'échelle
du pays la nature publique du bien
engage la responsabilité de l'État il
peut actionner le levier de la fiscalité
plus d'impôts aujourd'hui ou le levier
de l'endettement plus d'impôts demain en
découle alors les questions du
consentement et de l'assujettissement à
l'impôt ainsi que la soutenabilité de la
dette publique boulait auquel on
enchaîne les générations futures l'État
central a besoin du Relais des
territoires le pacte vert européen doit
s'appuyer sur des initiatives en
provenance et à destination des
territoires existe déjà un fond vert de
thé de 2 milliards d'euros pour
l'investissement un tiers financement
pour la rénovation énergétique ou encore
une agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires fournissant l'ingénierie et
bientôt un porte-à-porte de la part de
BPI France à destination de 20000 PME et
otti afin de faciliter la décarbonation
de l'industrie sans oublier en région
Île-de-France une mise sous contrôle de
l'artificialisation mais aussi un
renforcement du maillage territorial
opéré par les transports en commun
s'ajoute la nécessité d'aller vers un
état et une bureaucratie de taille
maîtrisée bureaucratie omniprésente et
état hyperactif génère des effets
contre-productifs pour les territoires
pour preuve le projet de consigne des
bouteilles en plastique transparent
s'inscrivant dans l'objectif européen
d'un taux de collecte de 90% d'ici 2029
en concurrençant les packs jaunes
menacent la rentabilité des centres de
recyclage des territoires la lutte
contre les soupes de plastique dans les
océans l'équivalent d'un camion toutes
les minutes mérite mieux que ça la
solution peut-être le polycentrisme
d'une nouvelle gouvernance avec état
central et local BPI France et banque
des territoires les entreprises ETI PME
mais aussi des grands groupes
industriels ou non tous acteurs de ce
polycentrisme responsable et plus
autonome facilitant une innovation
bénéfique au plus grand nombre cherchons
à rendre compatible une dette verte
s'ajoutant au dettes existantes et
tranchant la question de nouveaux impôts
verts inévitable pour le rapport
pisaniferi mais contrariant l'annonce du
politique promettant plus de nouvelles
taxes ainsi forcé de constater que
nulissu n'est envisageable sans le
retour d'une croissance durable et
suffisante enfin gardons en mémoire ces
derniers encouragements de la Nobel
d'économie et du Nord au strum
l'objectif central des politiques
publiques devrait être plutôt de
faciliter le développement
d'institutions qui font ressortir ce
qu'il y a de meilleur chez les humains
[Musique]